hey what is up guys I'm Kim PhD here and
this is the Bose QuietComfort 35 the QC
35 s these are the successor to I guess
pretty much the gold standard for
premium noise cancelling headphones at
this point which is the bose qc25 these
have obviously you know that red and
black so they got some color we're going
on with them but these have been my
go-to for you know train rides and
flights for the past couple years so
naturally when you get a successor to
them you kinda have to wonder you know
what's different about them and are they
worth the difference in price on amazon
right now the qc25 are 300 bucks and the
new QC 35 are 350 bucks now in a pair of
really premium noise cancelling
headphones you look for a couple things
build quality comfort sound quality and
then of course how good the noise
cancellation actually is now build
quality is just fine here it's nearly
identical to the QC 25 s there are
pretty overall lightweight pair of
plastic built headphones pretty flexible
and that's actually what makes them so
comfortable that they're so light and
flexible and along with the super soft
foam on the top band and the super soft
leather ear cushions that go over your
ears all of this combines together to
make them really comfortable if anything
the QC 35 s are just a little bit
heavier than the 25 since there's now a
small rechargeable battery in them now
but you probably won't notice that so
wearing these headphones for long
periods of time like a long flight is
still no problem Comfort is a huge plus
for these now since they're wireless you
do have a couple other things to worry
about and those are the controls and
battery life controls have moved from
the inline wire and Mike on the qc25 two
buttons on the back of the right ear cup
here and they're all the same so the
play/pause controls the volume up and
down skipping tracks etc and they're all
pretty tactile quality buttons which is
important when you're pressing them
blind and battery life is also top of
the line now I've only had these for the
past couple days about the past week or
so but the 20-hour active battery life
seems to hold up now every time you turn
them on it tells you when the Bluetooth
is paired and it also gives you the
battery percentage of what's left so
when I turn it on last I had
63% so I feel like I could finish out
the rest of the week with a lot more
heavy listening of these and not have to
charge it till the weekend so that's
good and I feel like if you could listen
to pair of headphones for the entire
week and charge it once a week with a
lot of heavy listening you pretty much
don't have to think about it that much
so battery life is another strong plant
with these now sound quality is pretty
much exactly the same as a QC 25 s which
is to say pretty good but nothing
spectacular it's nothing that's going to
blow your mind at all it's just like a
normal pair of closed back headphones
you aren't buying these two monitor for
music production or anything like that
they're obviously very vibrant and
colored and I'd put them on par with
other 150 to $300 headphones in terms of
clarity and detail but again it's
wireless so that's nice and it actually
comes with a wire in the Box on the
bottom of these headphones you have a
micro USB charging port on the right ear
cup and yes you do get that mini cable
and a three-and-a-half millimeter
headphone jack on the left ear cup and
that wire is included to either plug it
into something that doesn't have
bluetooth and just listen to them like
normal headphones or plug it in and use
the headphones without noise
cancellation so if you just want regular
listening with no noise cancellation you
have to do it through the wire but you
can't do it wirelessly and then the
noise cancellation itself
Bo's does this pretty much better than
anyone else it's kind of what they're
best at there's microphones as you can
see all around the outsides of the
headphones to pick up outside noise and
frequencies and just cancel them out so
if you've heard bose noise-canceling
headphones before you know exactly what
i'm talking about it's great for flights
it's great for loud environments trains
buses basically anytime you want to
cancel out the outside world and just
hear your audio just listening to your
music isolated I mean that's why you buy
noise cancelling headphones in the first
place so I'm happy to say that Bose has
put together a complete package here
with the QC 35 s they'll be replacing my
QC 25 s even has things like NFC
built-in for quick bluetooth pairing by
tapping it to your Android phone so that
was convenient and there's the carrying
case as well that's pretty similar to
the one that qc25 s had since they fold
up the exact same way plus they carry
extra cables now - and again that's
ideal for traveling and just tossing the
headphones in a bag or a backpack or
something and there's the flying adapter
- since they know that people use these
a lot on planes so coming back to that
price difference basically if you want
to have specifically noise canceling
wireless headphones then you have to pay
the extra 50 bucks to go with the 35 s
but if you just want know is canceling
headphones and you don't really care
about the convenience of having no wire
then this is just fine the 25 s are
functionally pretty much exactly the
same as the QC 35 no wire slightly
shorter battery life single triple-a
battery also has a wire
50 bucks cheaper for the 25 s that's
their breakdown but bottom line is if
you're looking for noise cancelling
headphones in general in a premium sort
of $300 price range you should have
these on your shortlist either way
that's been it thank you for watching if
you have any other suggestions for
headphones or audio products or anything
else tech related you want me to take a
look at feel free to leave it in the
comments section right below that like
button and I'll be down there answering
your questions as well that's been it
thanks for watching and I'll talk to you
guys in the next one peace